A HOCKEY PROMOTER HAS A HUNCH,
SKIPPED THE SCORING BUT LET THE
PUNCH.
FINALLY PROFESSIONAL ICE
FIGHTING IS COMING TO AMERICA.
IT IS HOCKEY WITHOUT THE HOCKEY.
JUST THE FIGHTS.
IF ONLY THIS WAS AROUND FOR
TONYA HARDING COMPETED.
FIGHTERS GO HEAD-TO-HEAD ON THE
OPEN ICE WITH MINIMAL MMA STYLE
GLOVES.
THIS COULD BUT THE WORLD CUP TO
SHAME SINCE THE PEOPLE WRITHING
IN PAIN ON THE GROUND MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE INJURED.
APPARENTLY YOU DON'T FOLLOW
SOCCER.
GOOD FOR YOU.
THEY HELP THEIR FIRST SANCTIONE
EVENT THIS YEAR IN CANADA AND
NOW THE LEAVES ICE CORE
INTERNATIONALS BRINGING THEIR
FROSTED CUPS HERE NEXT MARCH.
WYOMING WILL BID ON WHO GETS TH
FIRST FIRST AMERICAN EVENT.
SAID THE LAWMAKER RESPONSIBLE
FOR BRINGING IT STATESIDE
HIMSELF, A FORMER MMA FIGHTER.
IT'S EVERYTHING WITH LOVE ABOUT
HOCKEY, THE FIGHTING.
THE PROMOTER SAYS LIKE BOXING
HIM ICE FIGHTING IS FAST AND
FURIOUS WITH LITTLE DOWNTIME
PICKED IT SOUNDS LIKE EVERETT I
THE MEN'S ROOM.
I JUST HOPE PRO ICE FIGHTING
WILL PERFORM BETTER THAN PRO IC
FIGHTING ABOUT THAT'S YOU SEEIN
RODENTS IN CATS APARTMENT.
THEY WOULD DO ANYTHING TO GET
OUT UP THAT.
IF YOU WERE GOVERNOR COME UP
WHAT YOU SUPPORT ICE FIGHTING
COMING TO NEW YORK STATE?
>> YES.
FIRST YOU COULD BE SKEPTICAL.
BUT THEN YOU WATCH THE VIDEO.
THIS IS FANTASTIC.
LIKE KITS OF THIS GENERATION CA
BUT THEY DON'T GET FIGHTING LIK
WE HAD BACK AT THE DAY.
WHAT YOU'RE WATCHING THE VIDEO
AND YOU ARE SEEING THE
ONE-ON-ONE FIGHTING, I WANT TO
SEE FOR ON FOUR, FIVE ON FIVE,
SIX ON SIX.
I WANT THEM TO PUT THE GLASS UP
AND GET THEM THROWN INTO THE
BOARDS AND BANGING ON THAT THIN
AND HOW MUCH WOULD WE PAY TO SE
TYRUS ON ICE SKATES DEFENDING
THAT CHAMPIONSHIP.
AND YOU KNOW WHO HE SHOULD FIGHT
, JULIE BANDERAS.
>> I WILL DO IT IN HEELS.
IS THAT MY TURN?
>> YES.
>> THAT WANT TO STEP OUT OF LINE
.
>> THAT IS SO UNLIKE YOU.
>> FIRST FALL LIKE THERE IS NO
NONVIOLENCE IN SPORTS IN ICE
HOCKEY SO STRAP ON SOME ICE
SKATES AND BEAT THE LIVING OUT
OF EACH OTHER.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A GREAT SPORT T
TEACH OUR CHILDREN, AWESOME,.
BUT THERE IS A POSITIVE PICKED
ONCE THEY GET THERE OUT OF THEM
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO TOO FAR T
ICE THEIR INJURIES BID THEY CAN
JUST FACEPLATE AND ICE.
I THINK THIS IS PARTICULARS.
WHO THOUGHT OF IT, OBVIOUSLY A
MAN.
>> SEXIST, ARE PREPARED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW WHO CAME UP WITH THIS,
MARY CURIE.
THAT WAS A MICRO- AGGRESSION.
KAT, COULDN'T THIS RELIEVE THE
NEED THAT WE HAVE FOUR FIGHTS A
FAST FOOD RESTAURANTS AND SUBWA
FIGHTS AND ALL THESE FIGHTS AND
AIRPLANES AND THEN THERE'S
FIGHTS AND BAKERIES.
>> KNOW, BUT I DO THINK IT IS
AWESOME.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT IT WAS SO
FASCINATING AS LONG AS YOU'RE
PLAYING HOCKEY ARE NOT GOING GE
ARRESTED.
THERE'S SO FEW PLACES YOU CAN B
PUBLICLY PUNCHING OUT SOMEBODY
NOT GOING TO GO TO JAIL ONE OF
THOSE PLACES INVOLVES THE MEN
WEARING ICE SKATES FOR THAT'S
COMPLETELY AMAZING.
SKEPTICAL OF WHAT.
I'M DEFINITELY GOING.
SHE WAS THAT ROCK CENTER.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS ICE-SKATING.
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO PUNCH THEM
WITH ICE SKATES ON.
THE OTHER THING I LOVE, IS I
LIKE AXING VARIABLES.
IT'S LIKE FIGHTING ON ICE,
WRESTLING UNDERWATER.
MMA AND THE BOUNCY CASTLE.
BOXING ON A MOVING TRAIN GOING
AROUND A MOUNTAIN IN SWITZERLAND
.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, TYPHUS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL.
>> I GOT A LITTLE GUY ARE FOUND
IN FRONT OF A LIVE STUDIO
AUDIENCE.
AND YOU APPLAUD.
THIS IS GOING TO SOUND WEIRD BU
I AM NOT A FAN OF THIS AND HERE
IS WHY WE HAVE DUMBED DOWN
SUCCESS IN THIS COUNTRY A LOT.
TO BE A BOXER IT TAKES
DEDICATION, SACRIFICE, KEEP AT
THE PUT OF THE WORK AND LEARN
THE SIGNS.
SO WE HAD FIGHTS WITH THEY WOUL
VIDEOTAPE PEOPLE BEATING EACH
OTHER FOR ABOUT $50.
I WAS BORN IN MASSACHUSETTS THA
I PLAY HOCKEY SO BE SOMEBODY --
IT WOULD BE BAD IF SOMEBODY GOT
ME ON ICE BUT IT GOES BACK TO
THE GUYS THAT DO THIS FOR A
COUPLE HUNDRED BUCKS IF THEY'RE
LUCKY WHO PUNCH THEIR TEETH OUT
AND THEN WHAT THAT IS THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS.
YOU SAY THAT THEY ARE TRAINED
ATHLETES AND YOU THROW TWO GUYS
IN A RING OR COULD DO BEATING U
EACH OTHER THEN WHAT HAPPENS
AFTERWARDS.
CINELLI WHAT ARE WOMEN TO SHOW
THEIR UP INSTAGRAM FOR MONEY AN
GUYS TO BEAT THAT OUT OF EACH
OTHER.
THEM ALL THESE DIFFERENT
FIGHTINGS NOW AND LET'S GET SOM
GIRLS TO BEAT EACH OTHER ON THE
ISOLATE ISOLATES DEFENSE SAID
THAT IS --
I WILL TAKE IT.
TO DO YOU WANT TO CANCEL ME?
>> THAT IS IT I'M STARTING THE
LETTER WRITING CAMPAIGN.
>> CHANGE.org.
IT JUST GOES BACK TO IT IS THE
LOWER AND THAT IS DOING THIS
AGAIN.
>> I SEE WHAT YOU MEAN.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BRING ME
DOWN.
I JUST WANT TO WATCH, WHICH IS
BASICALLY